there's new drama in the college bribery
scandal Laureen Lachlan and her daughter
Olivia Jade lay low for a while and
Olivia is back with a vengeance the 19
year old fired off the two-finger salute
her message to the tabloids crystal
clear it's Olivia's second social media
post since the scandal broke 22 weeks
ago Beatty has learned olivia has no
plans to return to USC in the fall
instead the beauty blogger wants to
focus on rebuilding her brand and her
business
we're told therapy has helped to bring
the family together Lori has apologized
many times and olivia has forgiven her
but still carries some resentment and
today casting was announced for the
blonde and brunette lead actresses for
lifetimes College Admissions scandal TV
movie the roles of the two moms won't be
written as Hollywood stars like Lori and
Felicity Huffman instead Penelope Ann
Miller plays a wealthy interior designer
ironically Penelope starred with
Felicity in the ABC series American
crime she's going to be fine it would
have been good for you to have been
appearing we were with Quinn star trek
discovery star Mia Kirchner has been
cast to play a businesswoman the movie
will air this fall and as for Felicity's
fate her sentencing is set for September
13th and prosecutors recommend she
served four months in prison
[Music]